Dude. I love eighties movies.
I wonder if it's about me being from the eighties and it being nostalgic, like,
are my kids going to like watching this? They're probably gonna be like, dad,
I don't want to watch another Sergio keto movie or whatever the.
What's his name? That's the guy from iron chef. By the way.
What's his name again? Iron chef dude. That is the,
that's a killer gig to have Mark Casca
discuss, discuss the cast goes one fire, spelled it wrong. Cool. The cast goes,
um, [inaudible] you gonna get it? Wow. That guy.
Dude. He hard. Antonio Banderas.
I don't know. Who's hot. Who's hotter
Than him. That either of them
seen like when Antonio Banderas came and did the Desperado, was that the movie,
was it the movie? He did Desperado a scene in a sassy,
but there was, nobody was sexier than
Intiman Doris honestly
was the sexiest in assassins.
And that's everybody knows that.
His hair.
This with the pubes coming out from the back,
like he had a Dick on the back of his.
Head.
I need to get a Dick on the back of my head and kinda of, um, kind of, uh,
uh, what do you call it,
Dude? Remember this? See where he closes the laptop. Oh God.
What he does when he does. Oh, I'm going to reenact it on this video here. What?
I'm going to do it.
Wow. The choices he makes
it's slow motion, dude.
He goes like that. This is how he does. He goes like this.
Wow. That's honestly, you.
Holly Fu would for not having him at least nominated for a golden globe and
assassins for that scene, dude,
closing a law make you don't understand making a choice.
That specific is as good as King speech.
It's as good as Colin Firth, dude,
Colin first and in King speech and Antonio Banderas.
When he closes the laptop and assassins both exactly the
best kind of caliber acting. I swear to God, Dina Del Lewis would look at that.
If he was smart and be like, wow, no, honestly,
that's better than I was in the human quilt or whatever the that movie was.
Dude, when he it.
What is he doing with his hand?
And it's slow motion when he opens his mouth. Dude,
who directed this amazing bro.
Oh, wow dude.
And you know Bandaras is so good because he is equal parts,
acting of the most intense that you can
possibly do, but also doesn't give a about it.
That's the best acting you can do it, especially in the he does.
Like when you have guns, like where you're like, okay, here we go. Here we go.
But that he doesn't give a about it. He's like, well, what's going on?
What's going on? What's going on? You know what I mean, dude, it's so dope.
He'll like, he'll like, he'll,
he'll bust into a door and his hair will come over his face and they'll be like,
okay, this is it. I might that tonight. But also it's all right tonight.
It's all right to get there. I might do tonight,
but it's her right to get there. That's it. I'm an acting teacher now babies.
I'm an acting teacher now. And that is the pinnacle of acting.
I might that tonight, but it's going to be all right together.
That's that's how you act in everything.
You think that King speech wasn't I wasn't thinking that
Antonio Bandera.
It also helps to be good at acting when you have hair that's long and,
and it can like go in front of your face when you're doing like crazy sweaty
scenes. It's secretly good acting. Wow man.
Amazing.
He's my favorite actor.
What was the Jean-Claude van Damme chunk. Lot of fan dude.
Jan cloud. The thing about Jean-Claude van Damme is he's four or five,
four foot eight. Probably. He's gotta be,
he's gotta be four foot eight. Oh, a skirt and under son-of-a-bitch.
Hey, how are you? Well, drums are my priority. You're like who opened the door?
And then you look down over here.
Would you like to cut me in my wife? One of my wife's is making Keach.
Yeah.
And then, and then, and then she's like,
the Kesha is almost done John [inaudible] and he's like.
For.
That's a good thing. Can't make more reader. We were done donating,
but I still want to do in the kitchen. Do you understand?
Do you guys want to see who can fit into a fireplace?
Do you want to see out of any of us who can fit into a fair place?
I bet it's me. And then other people are like, well that's not fair.
You're four foot eight. And he just goes, get out.
Wow, dude.
I'm fired to dive through it. That son of a,
dude, what is up with you gotta be SU what the man.
Action heroes. They don't have that anymore. That real specific. I mean,
Stallone was like, Oh,
that's so specific. That's why it was so good.
John Covina was like going to kick that son-of-a-bitch by sends us short
ordered, and then Seagal,
the director just like speak up.
And he was just like I do with my hands. You know,
when it was just doing the, like he's knitting a sweater. And then he just done.
I swear to God, one in some scenes, he's just doing like batting, like a cat,
like this lewd. So God doesn't even know martial arts. He just made up that.
He knows martial arts. Oh,
this is what Steven Seagal says about Vandam and other action stars. Wow.
Since you.
You've been here last four, hard to kill. We've had a lot of action.
Adventure stars popping out of the woodwork. Do you go watch the other guys?
What do you think of Jeff Speakman or, uh, Dom? You know,
do you know Bon Dom? Oh no. Oh, Oh, you've heard of, Oh.
Oh.
I was so mad that he's bringing it up.
You've heard of him. Oh, look how Matt, uh,
you you've heard of it.
Wait, wait, wait. He says no, no, no.
So confident has five girls in his green room right now.
And that's what he thought.
He literally thought this is what he thought when Arsenio hall,
as it Arsenio hall said, do you know how do you know van Dom?
And Stephen's a golf.
Literally went through this lightening quick as quick as it does his IQ though.
He thought, okay, well now,
now it's because this interview isn't about me.
He's actually about another action star.
And that's not fair because this is about me. Okay.
I'm the. I have four girls in my green room. All good.
And then cocked his head and said, no, you know, do you know Von Dom? No,
that's what he thought. Right?
Wow. Let's start with him. Steven,
what do you think of his work as a martial artist first? Oh boy.
I mean, cause like you guys go back.
To say, can we change the subject? What a hater dude, what a hater.
This world before you were movie stars. Right? I mean, he was like, uh,
a champion somewhere and right. I mean you, well, I mean, I,
I just promised all my mentors that I was going to be a good boy. Um,
I think that that's a matter of opinion that he was a champion anywhere.
I mean, dude,
imagine being that much of a piece of.
I mean just be like, yeah, yeah, he's good. He's good. He does his thing.
His movies kill whatever. it.
Wow. And I mean, you know,
I'm not being catty or anything. I wish the guy all the best,
but there are an awful lot of people who say that that's not true.
How about Jeff Speakman? Nice guy. Huh? Wow. I mean,
I was very good friends with his teacher. Uh, you know,
I park was a good friend of mine and he seems like a real good, a real good guy.
This kid I've never met him, but he seems like a good kid.
Who's the most legitimate Hollywood tough guy. In your opinion, you accepted,
of course. When you say tough guides, you mean martial artists or just timing.
I mean, Steven, for real,
if he was on the street and there was a situation you wanted this Hollywood
guide by your side because he could defend himself Jr.
It's that hard to think of a legit one. Can you.
Like he can't even consider another guy.
Should I laugh in your face?
Michael J. White. Can I laugh in your face dude? Wow, dude.
You know what? We're learning in this podcast today.
So many ways to slam somebody before a fight.
I mean,
it looks like the childrens are out from the play ground between
that and gonna laugh in your face right now. Oh, the
sheer
sock of being polite about being a
is on believable. Can I laugh in your face right now?
Oh, I gotta do that.
I imagine being in a relationship with Steven Seagal. Hey,
can you take the trash out and just him like this?
I have a question for you.
Where do you get off
this house?
This house that you're in with 40 rooms who paid for it?
Well, what do you mean? I mean, we both who paid for it. Well I just,
who paid for it? Well you did.
Do you think I've done enough work? What do you mean for,
do you think I've done enough work? Yes, Steven, I get,
I get where this is going. Sure. I get it. So why would I take out the trash?
Why would I do more work in the, that I, that I did the work for to pay for it
and then pick it up or killing someone for a.
Can I laugh in your face?
Yes. Well it's on hold on my belly. Yes.
Oh.
Wow. There's more.
Can I laugh in your face? Really? Yes.
Bolt-on shampooed bandana. Can I laugh in your face? Wow.
Shop NARS. I mean, Chuck is in his mid seventies.
He's probably 76 years old. Okay. 75, 76 years old.
Wow. Interesting. I don't know. I don't, I I've heard that. He's not, you know,
so I mean, I don't really want to get into, on film anyway. Uh,
you know, who's a tough guy. Why do I think Michael is a tough guy? No.
Do I think he's a martial artist? No. Do I think John?
Cloud's a tough guy in martial arts? No. Why not?
You know like why not the ego on the guy that he can't even speak out?
Another guy that's good is unbelievable. Imagine if that's how it wasn't comedy.
If somebody was just like, yeah, what do you think of,
what do you think of Joe coy? And I was just like,
can I laugh at your face right now? Kinda laugh in your face right now.
Tinkering. I don't think so. Okay. What do you think about Eric Griffin?
Can I love your face right now? Is he a special on Showtime?
Can I live in your face right now? Andrew San Dino Theo. Vaughn.
Can I love your face right now? Who do? I think he's a funny guy.
Like just on the street. Like what the?
Wow. That's amazing.
John Klein. Vaughn. Don, is that true? He got in a fight with you. No,
I it'd be like me squashing an ant.
It would be like me squashing. An ant dude.
Steven Seagal is like 60 here. Like.
Um, I don't know if I was in choir, but I remember reading something about that.
Jean-Claude van Damme for sure. Ate his girl's for real,
because he couldn't her because it wasn't tall enough. Careful. Now I wrote,
just look up on zipper pants and did her person.
You Larry? All he said he did like a spinning double one in front of me.
If he sees me, he runs well, he sent that he whooped some Akido or something.
I don't know how far.
If he sees me, he runs here's Jean-Claude van Damme in his youth. I mean,
how could you say Jehovah dam is not a martial artist.
He literally can kiss his knee standing up.
Wow. How could you say that?
That's so funny that somebody could be that insecure,
that they can't even give another guy a compliment.
Steven Seagal, his name. I wonder how much money he has.
He's like a real Republican, right? Like he like for Trump and.
I mean, of course he is. Of course he is who?
A guy like that would love a guy like Trump because Trump is so, you know,
whatever it is, what's that?
Oh, right. Yeah. He does a Putin.